que ucrania fue el punto débil del epen
y macrón supo aprovecharlo yo creo que
aquí hay que leer el debate desde lo que
estaba pasando ya antes sobre el tema
del poder adquisitivo mccoy intentó
sacar al open de sus casillas un poquito
provocando la se podría decir que ambos
tenían bastante propuestas relativamente
confusas yo me parece que no ha sido muy
claros a la hora de explicar su
propuesta ninguno de los dos sobre el
tema ruso y ucraniano yo creo que la
cosa ha ido un poco por la fácil que era
intentar provocar a marín doten con su
financiación
durante la campaña anterior donde pidió
prestado un banco ruso es cierto que ahí
también me habiendo pena entraba en
contradicciones sobre lo que ha sido la
postura de su partido a nivel europeo
pero también ha salido a la pelea y eso
es interesante porque creo que el marco
ha ido midiendo poco a poco a lo largo
de ese inicio del debate hasta qué punto
podía ir provocando a marvin de penn y
si esa provocación que había funcionado
en 2017 le iba a funcionar ahora de la
misma manera y me gustaría subrayar algo
y es el marco del primer tercio primer
cuarto del debate no es el mismo que hay
después decir hay una postura corporal
hay un tono hay una digamos un ataque a
la candidata manera en que es distinto a
lo que es la relación después ambos
después van a cambiar su actitud por lo
cual yo creo que más como estaba también
tanteando cómo iba a ser el debate en su
cuenta